faudrait parler vous qui êtes vous dans
man et vous êtes-vous timide
comment êtes-vous marie josé nat jeune
actrice en 1959
le public vous découvrez quelques
questions vite posé sur le film qui sort
et rapidement on embraye sur le physique
sur l'ultime puis la voix de marie josé
nat inefficace vous marie josé nat qui a
une voix qui trouble les hommes
or le petit ami de marie josé nat roger
dumas ce n'est pas votre fiancée oui oui
un fiancé définitif c'est comme ça à la
télé depuis tout le temps les actrices
jeune jolie sont interrogés parce
qu'elles sont jeunes et jolies la voix
de marie josé nat mais aussi les taches
de rousseur de marlène jobert bon pour
vous et en douceur maintenant c'est
évidemment un capital ils viennent
marie france pisier catalogué ingénue
oil emon apprentie comédienne est
forcément en manque de repères ici choir
le moyen de s'affirmer il certaine
indépendance vis-à-vis des hommes ou
marisa pavant simple faire-valoir au
festival de cannes en 73 le journaliste
s'entretient avec son partenaire à
l'écran sans s'adresser à la clis à
l'exception de ce mot à la fin élégant
narizah parents vous avez très bien
jouer votre rôle vous avez écouté avec
attention et un charme
c'est pas facile héros lui et des
stéréotypes que résumer miu miu en 1976
et qui perdure aujourd'hui un homme on
dit pas il est mignon il est charmant il
est gracieux il des îles petty à partir
des années 70 les actrices ont commencé
à se rebeller
fini les questions qui les met dans
l'embarras cette robe blanche de marie
france pisier est ce que ça révèle son
intérieur je me demande pourquoi c'est
toujours des filles à qui on demande de
jouer à ce petit jeu comme ça je dévoile
mon moi intérieur avec tact et
intelligence sera beaucoup plus drôle si
vous faisiez ce avec des garçons couette
et anémone est ce qu'elle a vraiment un
problème avec les hommes en sait qu'une
femme vous aurez poser d'autres
questions quelles questions par exemple
une femme se serait adressé à quelqu'un
enfin vous vous adressez à une femme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ou encore
isabelle adjani la petite isabelle
adjani comme on disait en 1974 la teigne
de mails de qualificatifs devant
derrière je m'étais ce qualificatif
parce que les gens me disent oui mais
les gens y mettent
wesley ça n'est pas méchant les
questions sur souvent bienveillante mais
pour marie france pisier ça reste de la
misogynie la misogynie elle prend une
allure tout à fait autre elle et elle
est très très inquiétante à mon avis
très très dangereuse parce que la
plupart du temps c'est elle prend le le
visage du paternalisme alors une
solution pour que ça change
l'éducation on pensait qu'il faut écrire
sur la même manière absolument
absolument
j'aimerais beaucoup que les hommes
apprennent à tricoter par exemple qui se
tricote leur petit plus le même
[Musique]